this video from BuzzFeed they're trying
to prove some sort of societal point so
they sent out plus-sized women which
truly is doing a disservice to most
plus-sized women to apparently break
down the barriers of what is deemed
acceptable for them to wear this is the
brilliant social commentary we've come
to expect from third wave third wave
feminists and and BuzzFeed let's roll
the first clip we are trying on clothes
that society has told us we shouldn't
wear no that's not society those are the
seams they're breaking because you can't
fit into those clothes it's not society
seems next clear long time ago someone
assembled a list of rules that bind all
plus-size women and if we just abide by
them people won't be mean to us isn't it
nice to just make completely
unsubstantiated but she put the little
checklist in the corner it must be real
a long time ago someone came up with
these rules and this is a problem and
we'll get to the overarching point this
is a problem with you see it with with
obviously feminists you see it with
people who have these sort of conspiracy
it's about the government is the
Illuminati man it's it's the system and
like there's some ultimate force that's
making these decisions and in pulling at
the purse strings if there was no what
do you think there was some double
secret patriarchy meaning hair hair from
henceforth no giant fat whales will be
allowed to wear Lululemon meeting
adjourned there was no meeting its viola
its biological evolution there are
reasons we're attracted to certain
things there was no meeting yeah I
honestly think like a whole bunch of
small white people in Europe made up
fashion rules and now we're supposed to
go buy it that's racist they were
actually invented by a fat African man
in the plains of Mozambique so you a
little bit little-known fact who do the
this is where it went back to while
we're just operating on completely
unsubstantiated some time next clip
don't wear stripes you can't wear crop
tops if you're this guy there's no
strapless dresses not wearing white
after Labor Day
these weren't it was a joke these are
merely suggestions they're merely
suggestions and by the way they're
taking suggestions and conflating them
with societal rules
and they're still not able to find any
there's no scraping the bottom of the
barrel they pull out white after labor
supplies to everybody it's not those fat
chicks it's an excuse for some guy to
kick your ass in the school locker room
because you wore white pants after
September sir we're supposed to be
dressed in a way that's flattering and
so all these rules are supposed to make
us look flattering I hate the word
flattering so much that I would rather
wear a steel tampon then hear this word
again okay first off if you're wearing a
steel tampon got news for you that's a
dildo so again you seem to have problems
understanding definitions of words I
hate the word flattering just like
clothes that fit by the way this isn't
by the way they're throwing dirt in the
face of the people who are there to help
them when you read articles saying like
hey this is flattering the plus-sized
women wear vertical stripes maybe don't
wear this kind of don't wear a sheer
dress maybe wear something with sequins
floral patterns are flattering these are
people trying to sell them their
plus-size clothing which they demand to
be on the cover of every single magazine
I don't want you use the word flattering
okay you'd prefer we give you clothes
that are unflattering because guess what
that makes our job a whole lot easier
everyone wears clothes that are
flattering and here's the truth we wear
clothes for other people you wear them
so when you go out into society
you you are accepted as a decent human
being who takes the time to put
themselves together we're not wearing
them for ourselves that's why when
you're home you are sweatpants or
pajamas or in the studio no pants if
that were acceptable people in society
would do that everyone wears clothes
that are this is not exclusive to
plus-sized chicks and that's the problem
is the victim complex here I hate the
word flattering like we're sitting here
today going like oh my gosh I can't
believe that we're expected to wear
clothes that are so screwed up all each
say is going to be very different
one day I'll probably be loving life and
the next day I'll probably be hating it
so basically I'll be like my 13 year old
self exactly straight from the horses or
hippopotamus
hippopotamuses mouths I can't get hit
those you can't hit let's give up a hit
though straight from The Hungry Hungry
Hippos mouth here's the they admit third
wave feminism intersectional feminists
or as mature as a thirteen-year-old they
cannot be expected
to exceed the maturity of a
thirteen-year-old here's just like
Barbra Streisand Adobe seed recently
she's been blaming Donald Trump for
getting for gaining weight because he
makes her sad so she's eating pancakes
and getting fat seems like something a
thirteen-year-old would say it's very
stupid it's not very adult to act that
way just like a girl saying the entire
it depends entirely on how people react
to me and validate me and if they
validate me in the exact way that I want
to be validated I'll either be fine
or throw a temper tantrum like I'm the
kid from hook I have always enjoyed like
showing a little bit of like butt cheek
in the back but the problem is is it
like you can't show butt cheek in the
back without showing it front cheek in
the front what what that means in the
video what does that mean front cheek in
the front I don't think you know we
found I think we dug something out what
do we have and that's what this is about
do you see what just happened here yeah
this whole thing is about empowerment
and doing it for yourself and her entire
day is dictated by somebody else
complimenting her I just do this for I
don't care what you think
what and by the way this is not a
compliment on your degree in
astrophysics or nuclear science this is
a compliment on how you look in shorts
so here's something important to note
this is a sleight-of-hand that occurs
all the time when we deal with this
whole plus size and fat pride movement
right we assume that it's about the
inner beauty that's about the
personality that something really it's
about what's on the inside that counts
but that's not what they're advertising
this is entirely skin deep it is
narcissistic it is completely shallow
every bit as much as the skinny models
who they hate the skinny [ __ ] who
they don't like the only difference is
they weren't willing to do the crunches
I don't care what you think my you look
lovely I can't you are just the thing
next clip getting to reprogram myself
was a a miracle and being really opened
me up to more credit card debt in the
future whenever I see something cute
okay here we go when you're talking
about the personality situation right we
don't let's go with this okay everything
here has been about how you look
everything has been this this this
Arceus ISM complex of how people view
you in society based entirely on your
clothes and your makeup and here we have
the clothes it's not really personality
based it's certainly not about their
moral fiber their integrity or their
character just your fiscal
responsibility but we'll take it you're
so fat and shallow we'll take it if you
show that you're bad at it literally
everything I know about you thus far I
can't stand
next clip you have got to wear what you
want to wear if you feel beautiful and
confident in a certain item go for it
like I don't care if you have two
followers on Instagram or a million
followers on Instagram you post that
selfie and whatever clothes you want and
you will look good and it doesn't matter
because you're doing it for you
falls falls falls falls first off you
post an Instagram selfie to Instagram
you might not look good okay she said
you'll look good
no you won't most of the time you won't
especially if you're taking your
previous guidelines if I hate the word
flattering I don't want to wear anything
flattering
take your unflattering clothes that
don't fit you and post it to Instagram
you won't look good by the way no one
cares it doesn't matter you're doing it
for you that's incorrect because you
just put a measurement on it whether you
have one followers or a million
followers you are posting it entirely
for validation from someone else this is
the ultimate irony these people in the
plus-size movement in the fad pride
movement trying to tell young girls who
by the way may be overweight and I
understand that I'm not insensitive to
it but you are telling them to find
identity in the very thing that you
claim to hate which is shallow skin deep
superficial judgment and then you say
but you upload that picture of you and
your clothes or you and your bikini to
Instagram and it and get your valley
because that's what you do to Valley the
metric is how many followers on
validation but if they don't it doesn't
matter cuz you're doing it for you if
you're doing it for you just get in the
tub look down at yourself naked say okay
it's self-esteem currency and these
people should be bankrupt you should be
you should I I deserve just as much self
esteem as you do no you don't you don't
you have an earned self-esteem it's like
dr. Peterson says you can't force me to
respect you you can't force somebody
else out there to find you attractive
you can't force clothes to look good on
you you can't force men to no longer
find certain features that we've
biologically evolved to deem attractive
no longer attractive you can't force
that upon someone else let's get let's
get let's get into some talking about
unhealthy body images for when there's
there's the problem here is again
this victim culture whether it's black
lives matter whether its 1% versus the
99% or you know big fat women on
BuzzFeed telling you that they don't
want to wear flattering clothes but you
better like their picture on Instagram
anyway there are unintended consequences
that create actual victims but first
let's get into it
okay the average woman right now in the
United States is 166 pounds okay you're
considered obese if you are over about
170 pounds in the United States if you
look at these charts so what these women
are trying to claim is oh I would
venture there they're much more than 166
pounds by the way that's just the
average here's the thing we're obese as
a nation right now so this isn't my
doctor told me to when you're doing
these averages I have hypothyroidism so
I can put on weight really really
quickly so you have to check things your
TSH t3 t4 I won't bore you with the
technicality but I spoke with my doctor
I said okay what should my TSH be he
said okay there are two ways to look at
this most doctors will say between 0.5
and 5 about should be your blood level
of TSH I said okay he said but that's
not what I do
I said what do you mean he said that
level 0.5 to 5 includes everyone in
society who has hypothyroidism or
metabolic syndrome or diabetes so that
point 5 to 5 includes people who would
skew that scale very unhealthily so for
me I'd like to see it between 0.5 and
2/5 wow that makes remarkable sense so
when you remove people who are obese the
average healthy weight for a female
around that average height of 5 3 5 4 5
5 is about a hundred and thirty pounds
give or take 20 as you get taller
give or take 30 we know what is healthy
and here's the thing there's a wide
spectrum there most guys will find you
attractive if you're somewhere on that
graph outside of what is considered
morbidly obese so who are the unintended
victims what are the unintended
consequences here you have men young men
out there right now but Milo talked
about this christina hoff sommers talks
about this thus exoddus who are
terrified of engaging in relationships
with women because women have become
screeching angry and they feel entitled
to validation on every front of their
life whether they've earned it or not
they feel entitled to say you're
beautiful inside and out you're perfect
even if they're not they feel as though
they should be told they're perfect in
any kind of clothes and they're not
plus-sized and they're wonderful even if
they're not and what are you doing you
are creating a guilt complex in young
men who cannot control what they're
attracted to they can't help but they
were born this way born this way they
like women the same way men throughout
the beginning of time have liked women
and the good thing is there's a range
you can have a Marilyn Monroe you can
have an Audrey Hepburn they're not
asking you to be a supermodel they still
want to see you naked boys men men who
are married to you they don't expect you
to be perfect they still like seeing
naked women in that same breath if
you're a land whale most men won't find
you attractive and most clothes makers
won't make tarps that fit that kind of a
specialized clothing category that's not
their fault it's your fault and if
you're going to go on Instagram or
you're going to go on YouTube you're
going to go on Twitter and you're going
to demand that they validate you and
when they don't demand that they are
censored guess what I don't care if
you're plus-sized you are the bad guy
not them hey if you like this clip
you're like most of the Internet you
have a short attention span but it was
taken from the full show you can see it
in the Box playing next to me that's
once a week on Thursdays full one and a
half hour show or you can join the mug
club for the daily show we have to take
some of that off YouTube because they're
monitoring us and censoring our words